a spa by sleep cycle de vie stable et
belta bros mis à part ce billet pour la
demie a d'abord stoppé pour la pomme
pariétaux
[Musique]
un voyage était
assis aux inconnus
comme des marchandises
on vous a remplacé individuel ces lieux
dont on
[Musique]
c'est y ait des dizaines
seigneur
il est visé par deux
mais me tais
gilbert
[Musique]
et lorsqu'elles sont arrivées en france
qu'elle se sont évadés elle avait gardé
intacte cette motivation
cette obstination à combattre le
fascisme et elles ont trouvé le même
enthousiasme de combat avec nos
partisans français
elles se sont ils se sont compris
rapidement malgré la barrière de la
langue
et ils ont organisé cette évasion
c'était une langue un long processus une
langue organisation qui a pu se réaliser
avec succès
[Musique]
chaque jour épuisé par des nuits sans
sommeil
[Musique]
de là m
votre chemin de croix fort aimable
ce n'est jamais bon
le monde
[Musique]
et
mourad umm paca ligne on trouve li ims
cazalet loubet rue des chartreux au
siège no ce voyage est mené 3 jeux
suivants pour faire sauter le bc
d'assassinats de femmes héroïques qui
ont marqué l'histoire
[Musique]
joe musique
vous avez été
[Musique]
il
ne pas oublier
pour que jouent les enfants sages et
vous étiez
[Musique]